president biden not done attacking half
the country with nine weeks to go until
the midterm elections the nasty words
kept spilling out as joe hit the
campaign trail over the labor day
weekend biden even coming up with a new
nickname for his political foes
not every republican is a maga
republican not every republican embraces
that extreme ideology i know because
i've been able to work with mainstream
republicans my whole career
but the extreme maga republicans in
congress have chosen to go backwards
full of anger violence hate and division
the biggest contrast
from what mega republicans the extreme
right the the
the trumpies
trumpies look at the energy behind him
the media is running with biden's good
versus the evil narrative by hyping a
new american civil war
these days it feels like we are not just
at the brink of a civil war but that one
has already begun trump supporters are
already speaking the language of
violence they're threatening the fbi the
doj the state itself and this is all as
they defend their dear leader it is a
fascist movement that has embraced white
nationalism and wants to impose its
religious beliefs as law it's no longer
republicans versus democrat it's
americans versus megan it could be more
dangerous than 1860 or the 1930s in 1861
they were sort of dispersed but they
couldn't
uh can conspire together and decide how
to attack the capital as they did on the
6th of january on social media
jesse welcome back okay
i think what we saw there is what why
historians should never be on twitter
because he he is now he now sounds like
a a freshman in college complete his
hair is on fire that's supposed to be a
reputable historian there are three
historians now that are losing their
minds they've gone crazy it's got to be
social media how do you feel being a
trumpy
i liked ultra maga better yeah it
sounded cooler that's why i mean they're
reading off the same teleprompter the
media joe biden they'll just put jim
crow in there they'll put ultra mega
fascists they're all just reading from
the same script but the people aren't
buying it do you see joe out there in
milwaukee now this was a weekend no one
had a job they didn't have anything else
to go to do see you have the guy that
won 80 million votes
where's his base
where are the biden voters sitting there
like i've had more people in my backyard
at a barbecue than we're at that rally
and they're going to have to redefine
what the word rally means because that
was not a rally
everybody knows that something's fishy
going on with that guy now greg when you
stink at something you have to point
fingers and i know this personally i've
done it my whole life it's the whiskey
you know it's the it's the producers you
know if we all knew we had a good
quarterback i was always wide open
harold if they could just get me the
ball
and that's what you do when you stink
and that's why people that's thinking
stuff go into politics because there's
always someone to blame you know you can
run the economy into a recession you can
jack up inflation crime wave but then
you say oh
it's donald trump and the republicans
and that's what they want to hear
in a way politics is so stupid you could
just screw things up and then you
throw red meat to your base and they
clap but the republicans have to meet
biden head on if they're being called
extreme this is what you do
you say oh you guys you guys are calling
us extreme you guys want to talk about
transgender sex education to
six-year-olds you want the six-year-olds
listening to sex talk with masks on and
you're telling the six-year-old with a
mask on they're also racist and the
school they're going to is abe lincoln
elementary and he's racist so we're
going to change the name of that and if
parents complain we're going to wire tap
your phone
craig they want to empty the prisons and
open up the border and they want to
power the economy with windmills
god's looking down and laughing at them
he put the oil in the ground he doesn't
want the wind to power i mean it's
stupid and and then and then you can
just use that argument though but go
ahead
wind is for birds greg it's not for
power oil is for the energy and and then
you guys he comes out and he just starts
bribing liberals that went to law school
with ten thousand dollar checks and they
get out of law school they can't define
what a woman is and he just puts them on
the supreme court greg yes this guy is
insane he just came out
and and said that republicans are a
threat to democracy this is the guy in
the fbi that just rigged the last
election and then raided his political
opponents house
trump got impeached for asking to
investigate joe biden joe biden actually
is investigating donald trump no one's
talking about abuse of power no one's
talking about it at all why aren't they
talking about it greg because they're
reading from a teleprompter in msnbc i
just like that you keep saying my name
he never does that that's a new image
too i know i can tell that's so sweet
you know dana uh he i was going to ask
you about what how the republicans
should respond
but
they are doing something right they're
stoking fear which is effective and
number two they're kind of trying to
take the crime issue away from the
republicans by saying if you don't
condemn january 6 how can you be how can
you back the blue shouldn't the
republicans be going head-on with the
crime stuff when the stats are bolstered
and every day we hear terrible stories
about criminals recidivism it's pretty
amazing to have within a month
to have the republicans
look like they had
the midterm election on a silver platter
not saying a red wave we don't have
jessie never said
and now a month later we're sitting
there going oh my gosh are they going to
win now there's i think a part of this
is media narrative uh part of it is that
you have people starting to focus but
there is some reality here that the
republicans on a couple of different
issues won
being the abortion issue
they had the opportunity to be on
offense to continue on offense and talk
about extreme i mean that that is where
it's an ugly debate
but it might be the truthful one that we
all need to have if we want to talk
about extremes because republicans are
going to be accused of being for a ban
when they're maybe not most likely not
but many of them have not said that and
that nobody is going back to them and
saying but you are okay with killing
babies up until the ninth month yeah how
can that be so the other thing about joe
biden is that if you are in your fifth
day of trying to explain what you meant
in your death star speech but who you
were talking about and you could have a
whole lineup because like you yeah you
are in that group you yeah you're not in
that group you're on the group but
you're not in the group they are
constantly having to do that so nobody's
talking about the next step for them
they're talking about how weird the
tactic is and i do think that the
republicans have to figure out something
like pronto yeah you know uh judge dana
as well as other notable uh voices has
pointed out the contrast between what
happens on social media and cable news
versus reality these people believe
there's a civil war going on but then
you go outside you talk to your neighbor
you go you go to starbucks and life is
life just goes on it's like a weird
they need you to believe in this kind of
bizarre fantasy because without it then
they have to deal with reality yeah they
want you to think we're at each other's
throats and that we're killing each
other and you go out and everybody is
you know you go to dunkin donuts or
wherever you go everybody's a pal
opening the door you know it doesn't
matter what color you are or what what
level you're at i mean everybody's like
morning morning morning more you know i
mean america is really okay but my
favorite part of that speech that biden
said he said you know those republicans
are taking us backwards really i think
it's the democrats have taken us
backwards because when you look at
children in terms of education because
the democrats wouldn't open the schools
our kids now are suffering and now at a
huge percentage in terms of brown and
black children unfortunately negatively
compared to other kids around the world
but also they're saying you know um
you we
the republicans want to go backwards we
don't want to go backwards i want to go
backwards because when donald trump left
inflation was something like what two
percent 1.2 percent gas was 250 a gallon
the price of food was affordable for
most people we had safe streets and we
didn't have a record crime rate like we
have right now so i don't know what the
problem is with the past we've had a
good for a period of time we're in a
hellhole right now in joe biden i mean
the guy loves division he is the divider
in chief
here first uh great to be back good to
see you
i'm sure uh you probably share some of
the same feelings we do but you might uh
deviate in some aspects of it what might
that be it's good to get your back
so there are four political parties in
our country right now
uh there are the maga republicans
they're the mainstream conservative
republicans that i that i largely grew
up with and served with in congress
they're the progressive democrats who
are on the periphery in my party in my
mind and then they're moderate democrats
where i'd like to think i sit
elections are about choices and you have
to give people
a choice uh that that they can accept
and most campaigns are about moving the
country forward judge i appreciate the
way you describe that and that forward
could be we want those things again
but campaigns are always one in the
middle
and the campaign that best attracts
independence
to their side is the campaign that is
likeliest to win
um president former president trump
called i think uh president biden an
enemy of the state i think he called
this last week and might have called the
doj and fbi
vicious monsters i think president biden
said some awful things personal things
about a mag of republicans dennis tried
to backtrack a bit look this is the
election season and these things happen
i do hope that
those in politics today don't don't ever
give up on people i heard a great
commentator over the weekend make the
point that that a lot of americans
experience pain and disappointment they
experience unrest and turmoil in their
lives and politicians sometimes speak to
that pain in ways that i sometimes wish
they wouldn't even though some are on my
side and sometimes they're not but when
elections are over you have to govern
and i think one of the the great
shortcomings of our political system
which is over promised and
underdelivered now for 50 years but
where it has really fallen is that after
the election no one is able to govern
now whether it's democrats in office
even democrats control the whole thing
and when republicans control the whole
thing why because there are four parties
and we have to begin not only to speak
to one another but there has to be a
commitment after the after the end of
these campaigns to actually want to
solve people's problems even if we
disagree you got to want to solve
people's problems and i think the party
that does that best
is going to win the majority or keep the
majority in the house in the senate
that's way too nuanced
it's got to be us and them you can't do
us them us them that's just too
confusing
too many you can't have four parties
yeah and what about fascists yeah where
are the fascists i thought i had them
as a semi-fascist i call you a
semi-social kidding i did not have
fascists i touched what it said
all right coming up next chicago mayor
lori lightfoot melting down over
migrants showing up in her city and
questioning texas governor greg abbott's
faith hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now